[Musique]
bienvenue quartier dominante sur les
hauteurs du marigot c'est ici à
Pierre-Louis Michalon planté fleurs
gravé Hoche pour Gloria en aléatoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puisque ma maman est née il trouvait
coup bah là tout le monde qui vivait ici
les parties puisque
énergie vibration positif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est exactement la monatekaré l'autori
les nous sortir jouer musique la nuit
sortie fait un spectacle il menait moins
monté
comme quoi que mon petit moment passé
bien et puis nous a discuté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fini visiter ici
[Musique]
pour
un coup à la divinité Pierre-Louis
Michalon aimerait avoir le soutien des
collectivités pour entretenir l'espace
courbarine puis c'est énergie vibrations
positive c'est fausse